[Applause]
welcome I'm James I'm your host for the
weekend
setting aside I'm sure you guys are
exhausted from the trip yeah let's raise
a toast make this the most incredible
weekend and make it a trip that we will
never forget that's the guy that I saw
in our driveway that guy was in your
driveway do you know it yeah it sector
my neighbor Oh God
how long has she been missing two weeks
the family at his post he's in case
anyone saw anything we've got a lot of
reported missing girls was last year
that's the exact same necklace it's on
the flyer why do you think she's stayed
here you know anything about this she
looks familiar
I found this necklace in my room and
it's the exact same necklace in the fire
you know what she was a guest here
actually she originally stated Hector's
something wasn't working about his place
so she rebooked with me her last night
in town about the pendant I mean people
forget things here all the time you know
I don't believe him I think he knows
about that missing girl I heard that
some other girls had gone missing I just
wondered if you guys have found a
connection between them
we talked to James everything clears out
either the new suspects
[Music]
is that neighborhood
[Music]
don't come any closer
you're not safe in this home the things
keep happening to the people who stay
there that more than one girl stayed
here and then mysteriously went missing
why'd you take Jennifer's necklace for
my room and hide it in your office what
were you doing snooping her out of my
office I know she's right five girls
have gone missing after they stayed here
i don't livi the assets that I collect
from my foreign clients just let us
leave
you just couldn't let it go I still owe
my client or girl
you
you